so
uh good evening everybody uh this is the
25th uh by the cambridge meetup
uh and tonight we have uh two talks
the first one is uh community building
through documentation
that will be presented by uh medici
mendoza
from one site and the second one
is optimizing future engineering
pipelines with a feature engine
by soledad from training data
so we plan to finish at
half past eight but we might overrun a
little bit
now uh just as an introduction for
the our meetup uh we are
we started in 2018 and we are the pi
data cambridge
uh local chapter for pi data
uh we have four organizers there is
federico
joris myself uh and ole we are all
here tonight and we are all volunteers
organizing
this group now as i said we are
pi data and pi data is part of num focus
in fact by data is an educational
program part of
num focus num focus if uh that's your
uh first meet up with us num focus is a
not-for-profit organization that
supports
open source uh and educational
initiatives
so you can see in the
list of projects on the left side of
this slide
many familiar names or familiar projects
that you use
every day and they are all
supported by non-focus
we have our code of conduct to abide
as members of the meet up and us
participants of the meet up then the
idea
is very simple you can check the full
code of conduct
on pareto's website but the idea is
behave professionally and don't treat
others
in a way that you wouldn't want to be
treated
uh yeah so important thing to
say is that uh we have a code of
conductor response team
which is basically all organizers plus
uh leonie who helps us in dealing
with any reports that we might have
a few updates from us
so as it is the end of the year and we
usually do the meet up in the last
wednesday each month for the december
one we will anticipate it a little bit
so it will be the 16th
we already have a speaker and we'll be
announcing it very soon
probably this or next week uh
also talking about speakers we are uh
at this point in the year composed of an
agenda for next year
so we need your help to find
more speakers
or referrals of speakers if you don't
want to
exactly volunteer to talk or if you have
a topic that you want to hear about
let us know will say how in a moment
there is also pie giving which is a
campaign from
non-focus to
raise awareness to people about donating
for the for the open source and and
their
uh calls so this is open and you can
check on
uh non-focus website
we also we have uh four sponsors which
we are very proud
so there is arm fetch ai num focus and
raspberry pi
and we we have a few uh updates from
them
so from arm which is the company i work
for
we have uh
actually many open positions so
if you want to have a look on our
website so
just a few to highlight the machine
learning devops engineer that's
in the middle between data science
and devops to make sure that everything
works as an infrastructure and
the data analysis part data
engineer positions all the way
if you want to from creating
machine learning frameworks and dealing
with the internals of
the likes of tensorflow and things
to data analysis uh positions
internal to uh to the company as well
so if you want to hear more about that
you can talk to myself or federico and
you can use
the meetup websites to reach out to us
if you like
or you can use this chat on the zoom
call
from raspberry pi our second sponsor
they have this very cool
streamings that they do uh weekly
about projects that children or
people in general actually can do
at home using raspberry pi to to create
cool things so every week there is a new
project
and you can uh have a look on their
raspberry pi foundation
website from our friends at
fetch ai they recently
launched a new project uh a smart cities
project in
munich and uh you can read more
about that on on fetch ai's
website so there are
also some uh other but
testnet that they call and uh
you also can read about their
api to create agents
on their website as well
as i said we are we are looking for we
are always looking for speakers but at
this point in the
year we are especially looking for
speakers to compose
our agenda for next year so you can
reach out to us
on twitter or uh via email as well
and that's that's all from me
i will hand over now to melissa
i guess you can share your screen
and just make a start thank you very
much
yay i think i got it right can you see
my screen right now
everything working yes i can yes okay
so uh first of all hi uh thank you so
much for inviting
me leandro uh it's a great pleasure to
be here
and um i'm a fellow brazilian like
leandro but i'm
i'm based in brazil so
[Music]
it's late afternoon here for me um
i appreciate that you're all here and i
hope we don't have any
other issues during the talk and
feel free to say something or ask
questions in the chat
i will also leave my twitter handle and
you can find me later
if you want to talk about uh what i'm
going to present
i'm going to talk about numpy because
it's a project that i've been involved
with uh for almost a year now
um so i have been a python user
since 2006 approximately
and i was studying mathematics so i did
my
my phd in belgium working with applied
math
and then i took an academic career
i went to be a professor at the
university here in brazil
but after almost 10 years at the
university i realized
i was not happy because i
i like software and i have always been
involved with
open source software free software
communities
and i really like python and i was
starting to use python more and more in
my research and i wanted to get involved
but i didn't know exactly how and it was
hard for me to split my family life work
life and then have
like open source contributions on top of
that
as a volunteer so
[Music]
i went to sci-fi one year
the conference in the us and i met ralph
commerce who is
working at one side and he mentioned
that they had
some job openings and i applied and now
i'm working at konsai
uh and and some of my time goes to numpy
so
i'm pretty happy about that changing
careers
at 38 years old is a bit challenging but
i
do i feel very happy right now
i've been working there since january
and
i propose this talk because i think it's
interesting to
explain what we've been doing at numpy
as a project but also trying to discuss
these topics for
other open source projects because i
think they are important so
i'm going to talk a bit about community
and linking all that
work that we're doing in documentation
and we would like to see
documentation improve our communities
and how can we do that
and then i'm also going to talk more
concretely about documentation
what we have been doing uh in the
documentation team
for numpy and uh
we have a nap so i'm going to explain
all that what that means
this documentation system that we've
been using to organize our documentation
and discuss some of the tools that we're
experimenting with
to try and bring this documentation to
people but also
to foster collaboration so we want more
people to contribute and we want people
to bring their own experiences
but they need a way in if they want to
do that so
we are trying to experiment with
different ways that people can
contribute to the
project
so first of all i want to talk about
community because
you cannot talk about an open source
project without talking about the
community because that's
what in the end makes the project and
makes
everything work so i really like
uh jonah bacon he has a nice quote that
i brought here
which is building a great community is
fundamentally about
creating an ecosystem in which people
produce
meaningful work are able to thrive
are motivated to keep growing and can
help sustain the future success of the
community
doing this while is all about
understanding the drivers and
motivations of people
and using tech as a means to address and
harness those drivers and motivations
don't let tech dominate your thinking
and i think that's a really powerful
quote
because it means so in the
brazilian python community we have this
uh
it's like a motto for the community that
says people
are more important than technology
so it's all about the community and it's
all about the people you bring
to work with you and the technology will
follow
if you have the best people around you
and if people are happy
and feeling motivated and feeling like
they are part of a nice
thing they will contribute and they will
bring their best
to the project to the community and to
their work
so uh this has been my experience
in the python community from the
beginning which is
that people value each other and try to
have each other's back
and in the brazilian python community
i've had uh
amazing experiences and i've made a
bunch of friends
but in volunteer projects
it is complicated sometimes to
create opportunities for new
contributors
when you don't have a fixed idea of
governance
or a roadmap or a way to
decide where your project is going and
what you want to do with the project
it might end up being just a bunch of
people working on the pieces that they
find more interesting
so for example you have a large open
source project like
numpy people will choose to work
on the things that are shiny on the
things that are you know
uh more exciting
but maintenance or
i don't know taking care of the ci and
doing stuff like that
is not as appealing to people and so
they may end up being neglected
and those are also important parts of
the project so
when you create a community that is more
diverse
in terms of experiences backgrounds
and the interests that people have
you help solve that problem because you
create space for people to
make contributions where they feel they
are better
fit to work on so
for example python had moved from
a bdfl benevolent dictator for life
to a steering council but there is some
sort of governance so people do
discuss where things are going and where
they want the language to be in the
future
and what kind of work needs to be done
to get there
and for numpy we do have a
student council there is a governance
but at the same time
there is not enough people working on
the project
to really diversify the kinds of
contributions that people do
and i think that's a common problem
because i've seen
the same kinds of issues in other
projects
and it is hard to solve when you have
only volunteer positions
so you have to make that extra effort to
create
a space for people to come
um this is also related to the famous
circus factor which is um formerly
called bus factor
uh which is the number that we say you
know like for this project
how many people would it take like
if they decided to join the circus
tomorrow
this would mean the project would die
and
for some of the projects that sustain
the whole pi data ecosystem like numpy
that number is pretty low and and that's
scary
because if those people are not there
the projects will die
or there will not be enough people to
make the project move forward
and you know do maintenance work
and create new features that will
eventually sustain all the rest of the
stack
and so it is important that we create a
community
that is ready to onboard new members
and to accept new kinds of contributions
so again when you talk about open source
communities
um there's a few things that we need to
be aware of
so for example like i said
documentation is not the first thing
that people choose to work
on most people go
straight into code and that's okay
that's no problem
but we do need some people to be
dedicated to documentation because it is
important
it's important for people developing the
code itself
and it's also important for people to
come into your project
and documentation is usually the first
encounter that people have with your
project
right and so it has to be pretty
it has to be organized and it has to
have a purpose
and a vision that lets people know
what kind of project they are meeting
and
do they have enough information to
decide to use this project or not
um are they feeling like the
level of experience that they have is
enough
to understand the documentation for the
project so there are many important
questions that sometimes are not
asked at all and and i'm going to
explain a little bit more about
documentation later but
relating to communities this might be a
first barrier of entry for example for
for a new user or a new contributor
if they think the documentation is not
good enough
so i i'm definitely not an expert in
code documentation but i've been a
teacher
and i do like creating educational
content
and i do know the impact that it has on
people
and as a former academic i i realized at
some point
that creating papers that maybe one or
two people are going to read like the
reviewers
maybe not that many other people are
going to read those papers but
educational content is going to impact
the lives of
many many people and especially in a
project as large
and as important as numpy
this is super super high profile in the
sense that people are going to
look at the document several times
and they are going to look for the
official sources
and if they cannot find it they will end
up in the
internet and and then you can find like
a bunch of tutorials a bunch of
explanations and other documents about
numpy but maybe they will be
outdated and then the user will try to
do something but they
will get an error because it's meant to
be used with python 2 instead of python
3
and those experiences might mean someone
will choose
another language over python for example
and so these are things that we need to
to be mindful of
however there is a problem
open source communities are not as open
as we would like them to be
um a 2017-17
github survey with 5 500 users i know
that's not a lot but
it's what they had available to research
users and developers concluded that 95
of the people who responded were men 3
were women
and 1 were non-binary what does that
mean
that means that something is not right
i would guess because um
when you look at github contributions
and you look at
who are the people who can actually
contribute
they are people who have free time
usually because it's really really hair
rare for you to be hired to work on open
source to be paid to work on open source
and we know that historically
marginalized groups
are usually not the people who have the
free time to contribute to those
projects
so um there are all sorts of problems
with the github tiles and i'm sure
you've
heard this before i have the picture of
the github tiles there
but you know the metrics that we're
using to
count contributions are also
biased in a way so
it does it
fails to acknowledge the contributions
of people who are doing important work
on these projects
for example when you do community work
when you organize a meetup
or when you do outreach when you do
project management all those things are
important contributions but they are not
counted
in your github profile so it ends up
as some sort of invisible labor
that is done by people in the community
but maybe not as acknowledged
as the code work and this is
all turning people away from doing
documentation
away from doing community organizing
away from doing project management
and that has an effect on the community
because if no one is organizing the
project
maybe the project doesn't have a roadmap
and that means
people are not able to find a place to
contin
to contribute because there is no
vision there's no space left for people
to come
and have their own contributions valued
inside the projects so
this is for me coming from academia this
is a bit like
publisher parish right which means that
you have
one way of contributing one way of
making a difference
and all the others don't matter so for
example if you can
publish a bunch of papers but you're a
bad teacher
no one will complain uh maybe your
students will complain but not the
university not
academia itself so
some people might mention that funding
might be a solution for this
i don't think we know yet i think this
is still an open question
but it's something that we have to be
aware of if we want to create
better projects and better communities
so in the same github survey that i
mentioned before
93 of contributors reported that
incomplete or outdated documentation is
a problem
so we are all aware that documentation
is not easy
and that we should have more of it but
60
of those contributors said that they
rarely
or never contribute to documentation
it does not have the same status as code
contributions and that is a fact
uh and many people see it as less
technical
and less important you can read more
about this in the paper that i'm
mentioning there so this is a really
cool article
um about the types roles and practices
of documentation
in data analytics open source software
libraries it's a nice
article discussing all those ideas that
i'm mentioning here
and a bit more so if you want to have
like an academic perspective that's the
one
you should look at so
all of this can be put into the soft
skills
um which is not a term that i like a lot
i i would prefer
something like people skills but at the
same time it is how many people know
them
um and it does many people
think that these are our skills that
don't take a lot of knowledge
to work on so it's something like oh
documentation is easy
so you can leave it for less or anyone
can do it so i'm not going to do it and
i i'll leave that to someone else to do
it
so we are definitely missing um
perspectives insights and good ideas
from our community because we are
pushing these people out people who
could make contributions that are not
code
so how does all that tie into
documentation so i've been talking about
documentation but
more on the side of community what can
we do
concretely about documentation in our
own projects
so that the situation improves
first of all let's think about what we
call documentation
so i know for a fact that my husband
works
also in technology but
in different contexts and for him
documentation is mostly the api
specification right
so it's what we would call the dot
strings
uh it's more like a technical
explanation of
what each function does but that's not
all
especially if you're considering an open
source project
uh you usually want to have some sort of
narrative documentation these are what
we usually call
tutorials how to's um
longer form explanations of how
you did the thing you did in your
project and
why it is done that way
and what are best practices for using
your project
and you know like quick start guides all
of that
those are effectively educational
content
documents so
these educational contents can come in
whatever media so for example uh
videos on youtube podcasts talking about
your project
and the communities around them blog
posts
all of those are also documentation
especially if they come from an official
source
inside the project um live stream now
this is a new
uh new not not exactly new but
many people are taking to twitch and
doing live coding sessions
i would also consider that documentation
because
many people will refer to these videos
later
to understand how things are done so you
can definitely consider that
documentation talks like the one that
i'm doing now
and you know like outreach in general
explaining how your project works
all of that um github comments
definitely documentation because people
will
look um you know search google for
an issue or a problem and they will end
up in a github
issue and they will read all the
comments to understand what's happening
and what they can do to
work around the problem so all of that
can be considered
documentation i i forgot to put in there
but also stack overflow
whatever forums you consider for
answering questions for example
those are definitely documentation so we
need to
understand that it's not just the little
page that you put
on your project that means documentation
it can be much
broader than that and many people will
prefer
different mediums and different kinds of
documentation
so they can understand the problem and
the projects better
so thinking about all that um like i
mentioned before
i think this there's a nice
movement around getting funding for open
source so people are realizing that
uh volunteer open source communities are
great
but they don't solve all the problems
that we need to solve
in order to have like robust reliable
projects
and sustainable communities so
the chen zuckerberg foundation which uh
sorry the chance zuckerberg initiative
which is czi has
a series of grants that they are giving
to open source projects
around uh biomedicine and
now i received one of those brands last
year
and that was basically geared
towards maintenance organizing the
governance
our website and the documentation so
i started working on the project because
of this funding
and i started working to create
the idea of restructure the numpy
documentation and create a dedicated
documentation fee
this is a very uncommon thing because
most funding um
initiatives and foundations
and places that give you money to work
on open source
they explicitly disallow you to work on
documentation or maintenance
they want you to do new features and we
all know that
this is not necessarily good for a
project a project such as numpy
doesn't need that much new features
but it does need a lot of maintenance
and
organizing and community building so
this was great and we just received news
that will be getting
a renewal so for next year we'll also be
working on documentation because of this
grant
and i think we should have more of that
so that's a great idea
um because of that we created a
documentation team
and we also did a nap which is the
equivalent for a numpy of a pep
so we have the python enhancement
proposals
we also have numpy enhancement proposals
so this was called net 44
about the restructure of numpy
documentation
so what is the restructure that we're
talking about
we decided to follow the documentation
system
as outlined by danielle bertida and some
people
at dvo which is a company that does
django
web applications um they started
considering this idea of
splitting your documentation into four
quadrants
so i'm going to explain a bit about the
quadrants
i'm not going to be super long they do
have a nice
website that you can visit at
documentation.dvo.com and it will
explain the whole documentation system
and it is what we're using for numpy
it's not not
different at all so the idea is that you
will have
uh first the tutorials
which are learning oriented so
this means that you will create a
document that will take your user
by the hand from one place to the next
and teach them something about your
project in the process
so it's not necessarily the most
efficient way of
reaching uh somewhere or the most
elegant way of solving a problem but it
is meant to teach a user about concepts
important concepts and best practices
for your
project so tutorials are the ones that
take the most
uh the most work to write i think
because you have to be very mindful
about doing things right
and explaining in the right way and
taking your user and
not leaving any holes in the reasoning
so that they understand where they're
going and why they are learning
what you're teaching them next you have
how-to guides
those are 100 problem oriented so you
want to solve something here's how you
do it
so you want to open a file this is how
you do it
you want to you know create invert
n by n matrix here's how you do it so
it's basically a series of steps like a
recipe
that you can take to solve a specific
problem and then user maybe can change
the steps and solve a different
related problem but that's about it
then you have explanations which are
for me the most difficult to understand
but also some of the most important so
uh
these are understanding oriented what
does that mean
it means you're going to explain to your
users
why your project does the thing it does
and how did you come to this conclusion
maybe historical
processes that made you make those
decisions
so for example in numpy explanation
would be
broadcasting how does that work and why
was it chosen as a strategy
for you know operating on matrices on
large arrays and how do you store those
arrays on disk
and things like that so it would be a
much more higher level of understanding
and also maybe not necessary in every
project
because for some projects you don't need
to explain all that much you just have
simple
how to's and tutorials would be
absolutely enough
and last but not least we have the
reference which is the one that we all
know which is the collection of dot
strings for your
uh your module your library your set of
functions
and which is just explaining uh which
kinds of parameters you put in
what do you get out of each function and
and how do you link those things
together
um so it is pretty simple when you look
at that
but at the same time i can tell you that
sometimes it's hard to classify
documents in one or other or another
quadrant so we are still figuring this
out on numpy for example we have no
uh explicit explanations uh
because they are all mixed in with the
reference because of
historically uh those explanations were
being done
inside each function so we didn't have a
lot of
separation for those concepts but it
does make sense and
and that's where we're going for
so there was a longer explanation here
but i think i'm gonna skip this because
uh
you can see this is the same table that
is on the document the dvo
website so you can check it out there
and it will explain a bit more about the
types of documents
so what is good documentation first
know your audience you should understand
who are your users and
who are you writing to do you want to
talk to your users do you want to talk
to new contributors do you want to talk
to your maintainers
um sometimes we don't have that clarity
and the documents that we write end up
being
missing the mark because we start
talking to users but we end up talking
to maintainers and and they don't fit so
both users are going to be dissatisfied
with the document
um it is easy and we all do it
which is dividing documents between
beginner intermediate and advanced for
example
if you're talking about tutorials but
sometimes it's easier to think about
profiles or personas for your users for
example
maybe someone is not super
familiar with numpy arrays but they are
very familiar with
matlab so they do have an understanding
of how to do indexing they do understand
how to do vectorization and all those
high level operations
but maybe just they just don't know the
syntax would you call this person a
beginner
i wouldn't so maybe it's more
interesting to think about personas and
the profiles of people who come looking
for your documentation so you can
reach them more directly with your
narrative documentation
of course it is always interesting to
use inclusive language so
avoiding local uh
sayings and you know like jargon and
slang that's important so that you can
reach more people when you write your
documentation
if you can have translations that is uh
ideal but of course it's not easy
especially if you're in a volunteer open
source project
and make sure to review updates and
rewrite your documentation
all the time because documentation also
rocks it's not just code
and you have to keep track of the
documentation of your project
you can see that in numpy we are having
trouble updating the dots all the time
because it it's just so large and it's
hard to keep track of but
it is important that you do
um finally think about who writes the
docs
so i think it's easy to get beginners or
newcomers to your project and direct
them to documentation oh you don't know
anything about our project
great go write documentation but is that
the more
appropriate solution because if you
think about it uh maybe a
person who is just arriving to your
project doesn't have the
appropriate insights to really explain
what's going on and write about best
practices
so this should be um
don't just direct all newcomers to your
project to write documentation
this is maybe not the best idea all the
time
but it is a way to enter the project if
you do it right
so just to finish um this is
one of the results of the documentation
team is that we created a new
repo called numpy tutorials and in this
repository we are looking for
um contributions in the form of jupiter
notebooks
so why did we do this um
the main documentation for numpy is done
in sphinx so using restructured text
many people who work with python will be
familiar with
restructure text and syncs and will know
that it can be
very complicated for new users
especially because you have to
um if you're building the documentation
for numpy
you have to kind of build the whole
project
locally and that may be a barrier of
entry if you just have like a good
educational material and you want to add
to the documentation we just don't know
how to build and how to link you know
open blasts and
do all those complicated stuff so we
thought about
allowing people to upload their jupiter
notebooks in a format that would be
appropriate
however we are having a lot of trouble
with this
why because everybody uh who has
dealt with jupiter notebooks on github
and
doing version control on them knows that
this is not a solved problem so we are
trying to experiment with some tools to
make this better
uh we starting from mist
so mist is um is a tool that allows you
to write
your sync's documentation but in
markdown instead of using restructuring
text
which is what most people will be more
familiar with
um there's a tool called called miss nb
so this allows you to connect jupiter
notebooks
um and write your documentation
and your notebooks in markdown and then
a third tool called jupitex will do the
conversion
between jupiter notebooks and markdown
documents
and will supposedly make it all work
together so this is still we are still
experimenting
with those tools and i would appreciate
if you have ideas or if you have
uh suggestions or if you want to discuss
this a bit more
or if you want to contribute feel free
to check the
repo out we are um
in the midst of organizing this tutorial
and and making sure the workflow works
for everybody
but contributions are always welcome
that's it that's what i had to say so
i'd like to hear uh your comments and
questions if you have them
and please reach out i'm on twitter i'm
at melissawm
and you can find me there you can send
me a dm or
mention me and we'll talk about it
thank you thank you very much for your
talk
uh i guess we can use the the chat
functionality to submit questions
i can read them out to you and as we
wait for
for questions uh in written form
i've i've got a couple questions uh to
start
and uh the first one is uh in the
beginning of your
talk you you were discussing about
diversity in open source projects
do would you have kind of a
one or two recommendations for open
source projects because
it seems that that recently open source
projects kind of woken up to this to
this issue
and they want to have more diversity in
the project
but they struggle to find people or
when when somebody appears they scare
them out for some reason
and and would you would you be able to
point some
things that you see on open source
projects that
would be helpful or wouldn't be so wrong
so yeah um i think there's this whole
issue for example i can speak about my
own experience
i cannot speak about other uh people
but from my own experience it has always
been really hard to find a free time to
to dedicate to open source projects
because of many
life issues and i think that's true for
a lot of people and
and many people end up not being able to
contribute because they
think they will have to dedicate too
much time to it
because it has like for example numpy
numpy can be
intimidating and you might think there's
like a very steep learning curve
until you can really make a contribution
so what we're trying to do is uh improve
the communication and and trying to be
so for example one of the things that
we're working on right now is mentoring
inside the project so we're trying to
pair people with mentors and
we are also experimenting with having
office hours
which is a period where one of the
maintainers is there and newcomers can
can you know join a zoom conversation
and ask questions or
try to talk about stuff that he tried to
do and couldn't do
maybe so i think it's a
very hard problem to solve because of
the volunteer
aspect but at the same time
we have to be aware that if people do
come
they need to have the space to
understand the project and to learn
and to be able to make their
contribution and that means mentoring
to me like i think it's
one of the best actions we can take to
improve diversity of course if people
don't come in the first place then
you have to solve that problem first uh
which is getting people to know your
project and to understand it
and to realize that they can do their
contribution
and i do believe that outreach is
important for that and that's why i'm
here also
because having uh the
having a way to meet the maintainers to
to you know understand what they're
doing and where you could
fit your contribution is what makes
people come to the project
i think but i don't think it's an easy
answer and i don't think i have all the
answers
i think it's an experimentation at this
point
yeah sure and i think uh the very fact
that
uh some people don't see that they kind
of represented in talks and things is
also uh a contribution
of uh when you see somebody like looks
like you
on a talk it feels like more welcome and
yeah
i think that's one more of the
contributions of your talk tonight
so uh let's see whether we got any other
questions
um yes we got one i'll read them out
i'll read it out to you
so melissa do you have any advice for
people that want to make a career change
like you did from academic research to
industry
that's a really hard question because it
depends on your
uh your career path in brazil
things are very different i think from
uh the united states and europe
and i think many other places in the
world because we
when we get to the university we take an
exam
when you want to be a professor you take
an exam
and then once you pass the exam you are
a tenured
professor that you will never lose your
job
so deciding to leave such a stable job
is hard so i think that it
also depends on your context it depends
uh how you
face your own career and your own
contributions but for me
it was mostly um i wanted to have
a larger impact let's say
i wanted to be able to contribute more i
thought in the university
my contributions were so limited and
that's why i wasn't happy with it so
what i did in terms of advice
i think it's being prepared for example
i was
in the university doing academic
scientific software
but i was studying about you know tdd i
was studying about
best practices for doing this or that
and i was studying other languages julia
fortran c you know so being ready
for when the opportunity comes i think
it's the best advice you can get
so i would say build your own
skill set and and based on
where you want to go and if you think
you want to leave
academia don't be stuck in the academia
mindset like go reach out and understand
and
come to these meetups i i would do this
all the time i would go talk to people
from industry all the time to understand
what did they need in industry what
would i need to know to get a job
outside of academia those things are
important so
build your own skill set and then you
you have the confidence i guess i don't
know if that
answers your question
yeah i i think that was very clear
and i i think we didn't get any
other questions so i have one to finish
on the
technical part of your talk regarding uh
specifically the documentation of numpy
which is i mean
fundamental piece of the whole
data science ecosystem so i was
thinking uh yeah i use numpy
documentation very often
i find it very good to be honest i
i got a question that you you mentioned
that it is hard to
link or it was hard to maintain numpy
documentation because you didn't have
the links between sources
and documentation
is this something that you you in this
new phase of numpy documentation are you
trying to propose a solution for that
as well i don't know did i say that i
don't know
because i think we do have um
[Music]
we do have links so i
i don't know if you mean like for
example if you
click on a function name will you go to
the source code
is that what you're mentioning so i mean
if if you have kind of a
tutorial that mentions some parts of the
code
that tutorial will wrought if the code
changes
is there kind of a cross-linking between
sources or something yeah there's no
cross-linking but if you do
for example those tutorials that are in
jupyter notebook format they can be
tested so you can run
a validation uh maybe github action
on them and then you can see if the
notebook runs all right
so if any of the commands fail because
of an api change or something like that
or
maybe something happens when the new
version is released
the notebook will fail and then you'll
know that you have to update the
documentation
right so yeah for those it does work
yeah
for the other documentation in the
website for example
i don't think so we do have dogcasts so
in a bunch of places there are dark
tests that will fail if you do
an api change for example and i think
that's extremely important to do yeah
that's something i should have included
in the talk yeah you should you should
definitely if you have the chance you
should validate using dog tests
or using some sort of validation on on
the large narrative documents like
we are doing in the joker notebooks
okay yeah well uh thank you very much
for the talk uh for the rest of the
audience
if you still have any question uh you
can post it on the chat
and i will read them out uh after uh
solid stock
uh in the uh before wrapping up the
the meetup for today yeah thank you very
much melissa
thank you yeah so are you still staying
in the meetup
yeah okay cool so
let's uh switch to the next talk and
uh next talk is uh from solida
do you so can you yes can you
you can share your screen
yeah i can see it can you see
yes just my screen or do you see people
here melissa
perfect okay
so thank you very much for
the invitation the opportunity to share
some of our work with you
today i want to talk about how we can
optimize future engineering
and more broadly machine learning
pipelines utilizing
python open source like numpy and
in for this talk in particular feature
engine which is an
open source project that we've developed
but before i jumped into the talk
i want to say a few words about who we
are
so in training data we are a group of
data scientists and software engineers
who have been working on
researching developing and putting in
production machine learning models
in various organizations and throughout
the years we faced
a number of challenges and we saw that
there is a little bit of a gap
between what you learn in uni or what
you can learn in online courses and what
you actually face
in the real life so after
troubleshooting these challenges and
finding some solutions we decided that
we wanted to close or narrow that gap
that's why we create several open source
server we create open source packages
like feature engine
that smooths the deployment of machine
learning pipelines and also make it more
easy to work with data as we engineer
our features
together with data analysis and we
create a number of
courses that we can find online on
feature engineering feature selection
more broadly machine learning pipelines
and then how to put the models in
production and how to test them
after they are in production
so with this said i want to
mention very briefly that within
organizations
we use machine learning to make
predictions for a variety of things
for example if we work in insurance we
can have
machine learning models to predict the
destiny of a claim so when a claim comes
in say after a car accident
we can have a machine learning model
that helps us decide
who is at fault if it is our customer if
it is the other person
and depending on who is at fault the
claim will follow a different path if we
work in insurance as well or in finance
we create models to anticipate fraud
and help us decide if a loan is
asked by a genuine person or by someone
that is impersonating someone else or if
when the
accident takes place if the claim is
genuine or if it is for example
exaggerated
we can also build models to predict
credit risk so if a person wants to take
a loan will they
be able to repay the loan so more
important these days is the prediction
of energy demand in particularly
in the light of renewable energy we also
can build models for
marketing and to determine
better premiums for insurance as well
and to predict customer churn
so as you can see there is a variety of
things
a variety of scenarios where we use
machine learning
models and even though the scenarios are
very different
they all have in common the fact that
the data science team
will try and gather data from various
sources like databases
third-party apis or the cloud and they
will try to feed that data into machine
learning models
to try and obtain the predictions that
will help the organization
work better
now unfortunately data is almost
never suitable to be used in a machine
learning model
as it comes from the source there are a
number of things that we need to
consider in terms of data formats
and in dates of data quality for example
it's very often our variables present
missing data
which is that basically there is no
information and we cannot perform
computations when we have no information
we need to transform this
lack of a value into a number
some data can also be in the form of
categories or strings
instead of numbers for example if we
work in insurance we will have the make
of a car
or we can have the city where the
applicant lives
takes values like manchester bristol
cambridge and we cannot perform
computations on those strings
again we need to transform those strings
into numbers
numerical variables will have certain
distributions
and sometimes those distributions are
not convenient
models will benefit if the distributions
were more spread
across the value range in other cases
some of the variables may present
outliers
and some models are sensitive to
outliers like linear regressions as we
see here
the variables in our data are in
different scales and there are
many models that are sensitive to scales
so
variables with bigger scales or bigger
magnitudes will tend to dominate over
the other variables
and this is true for many models like
principal component analysis
linear and logistic regression nearest
neighbors and also other
models like support vector machines and
neural networks will benefit of having
the variables in the same scale
some other data doesn't even come in the
form of variables they come in some
other forms like for example text and we
need to be able to create some features
from that text
or for example from images we need to be
able to
extract some features from that images
so that we can then perform
computations over them if we're working
in retail we will have for example
transactions
where for one customer we will have
multiple data points at multiple times
with various characteristics at each
time point
we can also have geolocation data we can
have
time series like for example the energy
consumption pattern of a household
and then we can also have date variables
and time variables
and we can certainly not
use this raw data as it is in fact we
need to transform the data quite
extensively
to remove these in data to remove to
encode variables
that are categorical into numbers to
modify distributions to modify
scales but also to extract features from
text
from images from date and time or to
create new features from transactions
or to flatten a time series into some
static features
or to convert some sort of distances for
example from geolocation data
so there's a lot that needs to be done
with the data that we have
in order to be able to mean to build
useful models
so at the end of the day a machine
learning pipeline looks
more or less like this that we see here
where there is
the first stage where we can we have to
gather the data
to take it to the space where the
scientists are going to work
then there is a stage of feature
engineering where we transform our
variables we create new features
then we train the model and then we need
to be able to score
new data to obtain the predictions that
we're going to solve
to some other system of our company or
organization
now in the future engineering stage
we saw that there is a lot that we need
to do we need to
carry out missing data amputation
categorical encoding
we can sort our variables into bins in a
process called discretization we can
transform
distributions we can create new features
we can combine new features
and this means that there is a lot to
code
to obtain all this information from our
raw data
when we train our model we can train a
variety of models
for example we can use linear models so
we can use decision trees
we can use nearest neighbors support
vector machines neural networks
we can also build several models and
stack them all together
and then make a decision that is
actually composed by the collective
decisions of many models
this means that there is a lot of
parameters
that we need to adjust and save and this
challenge is reproducibility
and we'll see in a minute
reproducibility between what
in the scoring layer what needs to
happen is that we're going to receive
one new observation or maybe one whole
batch of new observations
and this data is going to be in the raw
format so we need to carry out
the entire pipeline of feature
transformations
to remove the missing data to encode
categorical variables to transform the
variables create new features etc
and once we finish the pipeline of
transformations
only then we are ready to give that data
into the model to obtain the prediction
this means that we need to save all the
intermediate parameters
from the feature engineering pipeline
and from the machine learning model
so that we can retrieve them at a later
stage so we can modify the new data
to obtain the prediction so in essence
we need to save
the entire pipeline
when we research and build our models in
the research environment
we usually do it in jupiter notebooks
and if we are not very mindful about
it we tend to take the data divide it
into the train set
test set maybe one hold that sample and
then we build our entire code based on
these three data sets
the problem is that almost
certainly when we have our best model
and we
present it to the company someone from
the organization is going to come and
say can you actually score
this batch of customers from last month
i want to see how the model is doing in
recent data
and at this point you don't want to see
yourself in a position where you say um
actually
i can't because my jupiter notebook is
only tailored to process the train the
test and the holdout i cannot
accommodate yours
we need to develop the code in a way
that will allow us
to score pretty much whatever we are
asked to score
and finally when we deploy the model we
are not going to deploy jupiter
notebooks
we are going to transform this code into
production code into python scripts
write it into package or an api that
then we can deploy
so this means that
we're going to basically have to rewrite
everything that we have in the jupiter
notebook
in a way that is suitable for production
and we are also going to have to include
tests
which are often overlooked when we are
developing our code
in the jupiter notebook and when we do
this
we're going to face a lot of challenges
in reproducibility
reproducibility is between the research
environment
and the production environment what we
want to happen is that the model that we
built
in our jupiter notebook is identical
pretty much
to the model that we have in production
because we investigated the benefits of
the model and the model performance in
the jupiter notebook
so if that doesn't hold out into
production then we cannot guarantee
that the benefit that we saw is going to
hold on
so if we have to do this we want to
rewrite code
and include unit tests there is actually
a very big overhead
between research and production
so they put in a model in production it
takes a lot of time you have to
rewrite this
but fortunately if we use open source
we can minimize the amount of time that
we take to put our models in production
and also maximize reproducibility
so going back to this slide
unless we build very specific models
to suit a particular problem that we
have within an organization
almost always we are going to use
scikit-learn
because it's there because it's well
developed well tested
well documented it is perfect so
most often than not we build our models
utilizing scikit-learn
or if we're building some neural
networks we also use keras because
it's a wrapper that basically wraps the
neural networks so that they have also
the fit and predict functionality
now in the last years there's also been
developed a lot of
open source packages that capture the
feature engineering part
so in particular scikit-learn has
extended dramatically its functionality
to him
so that it allows us to perform a lot of
the
data transformation techniques that we
need to use in order to
make our data suitable for machine
learning models
but there are other packets packages
like category encoders
and feature engine that is the one that
we developed
the beauty of using open source
and particularly these packages that i
show here
is that because they all share the fit
transform fit predict functionality that
was designed in scikit-learn
we can accommodate all the
transformations within a pipeline
and i'm going to mention what the
pipeline is in a minute
but basically we are going to put all
the transformations
and the model in one object that then we
can save
to make the predictions and when we
deploy our model
when we pass from the jupyter notebook
to the production code to develop the
api
the only thing that we need to do is
just push
or copy or translate the code from the
notebook
to the api but because everything is
wrapped in one pico
this aspect is very simple and
straightforward
so utilizing open source
makes our life very easy because first
of all it reduces the amount of coding
that we need
why because all the functionality is
already
captured by the project the only thing
that we need to do is to call the
transformers or their estimators and
apply them on our data
second because we can accommodate all
the functionality within one single file
or pipeline then we can use just this
one file
to score every application that comes in
the future
packages are naturally controlled and
versioned
so we know exactly what is in each of
the versions
so if we developed a model in one
version of the package
then we can deploy that particular
version to maximize reproducibility we
are deploying the same code
and the packages include a lot of tests
for their functionality
so that means that we don't need to test
in production because the transformers
are already tested
the only thing that we need to be
careful is that the pipeline is working
as intended from end to end
so as you can see this utilizing open
source reduces
the amount of work that we need to do
quite dramatically
improves or optimizes the deployment
times
and makes a life very easy and for the
rest of the talk
i want to focus on this particular
aspect of utilizing open source that is
that it allows us to build
just one file with all the functionality
continuing to talk about these three
packages they all
contain the fit transform functionality
that was originally
developed by scikit-learn and is very
widely adopted by the community so every
package that comes now to the market
takes the fit transform functionality so
it makes it for users
much easier to learn how to use and to
integrate within their working
pipelines with the fit method
what the transformers from these
libraries do is
learn the parameters and there are a lot
of parameters that need to be learned
when we train an algorithm
but there are also a lot of parameters
that we need to learn when we
apply feature transformations because we
need to learn for example means or
medians or modes for imputation
we need to learn mappings from strings
to numbers
we need to learn for example
mathematical modifications that we are
going to apply to the variables
we need to learn how to combine the text
in order to create features so all of
these things
we usually learn from the training set
and then those parameters are stored and
with the transform method we recall
those parameters
and transform all the incoming data that
we have later on
because of this fit and transform
functionality what this means is that we
can accommodate
all the feature transformations within
the scikit-learn pipeline
the pipeline is a class that does
something that is very simple
it just applies one transformation after
the other
so the only thing that the pipeline does
is to take every transformer that it has
within it
and apply it one after the other on the
same data
so this way if we're using for example
feature engine
we can have a first step what we have
for example the missing
where we add a binary indicator for
missing variables
and here we can specify that we want to
add an indicator for variables 1 and
variable 2.
then in the second step we want to
perform median imputation
only of the variables that we see here
in the third step we want to impute
categorical variables
with for example one string missing so
we use another transformer from feature
engine and we indicate which variables
we want to modify
then maybe we want to discretize some of
the numerical variables in our data set
maybe we want to cap the outliers in
some other variables
we want to perform logarithmic
transformation of some other variables
we can combine features for example by
adding them all together into new
variables
you see how this goes so we can add as
many transformations as we want within
this data
together with this pipeline to get our
data ready
and at the end we can also include a
machine learning algorithm
in this case a lasso regression that
will take
in the data that was raw at the
beginning of the pipeline
but completely pre-processed just after
being fed into the lasso
which can now pre-process this data to
produce a prediction
once we assemble all the transformations
within the pipeline we only need to
apply the fit method
utilizing the training set and the
pipeline
is going to activate the fit method in
all the transformers within it
one after the other so that it learns
the parameters transforms the data so
that it can pass the transform data to
the next transformer
which will now learn the parameters
transform the data and pass it on to the
next one and so on
so after feeds all the transformers
within the pipeline
have learned all the parameters that
they need
in order to pre-process the data and
also by the end of it
the last regression was fit on the data
that was completely transformed
and the beauty of this pipeline is that
we can store it all together in one
people
so when someone from the organization
comes last minute and says
can you score the customers from last
month now you can say
actually yes i can you load the pico and
you just score the data
later on once the pipeline is completely
fit
with the method predict we can
make predictions of pretty much every
data set that we have we take in the raw
data
in this case the training set and make
the predictions
then we take in a road test set and make
some predictions
and like this we can take in pretty much
every data including live data once
our api is live and make the predictions
so i mentioned that these three
libraries support
functionality for future engineering
what specifically do they support
scikit-learn has quite an extensive
battery
of transformations for missing data so
it supports mean
median mode and arbitrary imputation
it supports one hot encoding and
replacing the categories by number
it supports three ways of discretization
it supports pretty much every
mathematical transformation that the
user wants to do on the variables
and it can combine features by
polynomial
expansion for example scikit-learn also
allows us to create features from text
and it has several transformers to
select the more important features or
predictive features from our data set
the two things that are not my favorite
from circle line
are the fact that it transforms the
entire data set
so you need additional code if you want
to transform just a group of variables
and not the entire data set and that it
returns numpy arrays
so i tend to miss the column names after
using cycle and transformers
feature engine has also an extensive
variety of
transformations for missing data
imputation
it also has many techniques to transform
the strings of categorical variables
into numbers it has the mainstream
discretization techniques and some fancy
techniques like discretizing using
decision trees
it can also transform data but very
specific transformations that i'm going
to name in a minute
it allows us to combine features with
several mathematical combinations like
product
mean average sum etc
from version one which is going to be
released in two weeks
it's also going to support feature
selection
and it also has a wrapper about
scikit-learn that allows us to apply
pretty much everything transformation
that we can find in scikit-learn but
only in a selective group of variables
um category encoders as the name
indicates it contains
transformers for categorical variables
so it has the most exhaustive battery of
categorical variable transformations
that are very useful i think for
organizations and also for data science
competition so i encourage you to go and
have a look
i'm going to focus the rest of the token
feature engine
feature engine has its dedicated website
it has extensive documentation
in utilizing read the docs and also it
has a github
repo it can be installed using pip
install
feature engine and it's also available
through conda
as i said it takes in a pandas data
frame and it returns a pandas data frame
this makes
the transformations carried out by
feature engine suitable also
both for data analysis and deployment
for data analysis because it returns
data frames which have variable names
and also can leverage all the power
of visualization that pandas provides
and for deployments because we can
integrate it into the pipeline and then
deploy just one pico
i mentioned already more or less the
data transformations that we can apply
with feature engine
for missing data imputation which can
perform imputation with the mean
the median with an arbitrary value or we
can
automate the the search for the
arbitrary value at the ends of the
distribution
with a transformer that is called end of
tail
for categorical variables we can perform
mode imputation or frequent category
imputation or we can replace the missing
value with any string that we like for
example missing
we can add binary indicators for missing
values like one or zeros indicating
which the value is missing or not and it
also performs random sample imputation
which means that it will extract samples
at random from the training set to fill
the missing values
in the test that we want to in the data
that we want to transform
for categorical encoding feature engine
supports one hotend coding
and also supports one hot encoding on
only the frequent categories
this is very useful when we have rare
data in
because it is very common that when we
score
new data we find categories that we
didn't find in the
training set so we need to do something
with that if we
already contemplated this by top one hot
encoding only the top categories then
this is automatically handled
we can also replace categories by the
count of observations per category
or the frequency of observations per
category
we can replace categories by numbers
arbitrarily
or in a way that is ordered following
the mean of the target so that
the category with the smallest number
say zero
has the highest mean of the target and
the category with the highest number has
the smallest mean of the target
we can also perform min encoding which
is basically replacing the category by
the mean of the target
we can perform weight of evidence that
was originally designed for its use in
finance
particularly with decision trees uh
sorry with logistic regression
and we can also perform some fancy
encoding utilizing decision trees so
that the
decision tree will make predictions
utilizing the strings
and then replace the categories by the
predictions of this decision tree
feature engine allows us to group rare
labels
into one umbrella term that we can call
rare or
other this is also helpful when we put
our models into production
because very often there is data
in the live data that was not present in
the train set
so then this data that is new for the
model will automatically be recoded as
rare and then the model knows how to
handle it
feature engine supports a number of
mathematical transformations like
logarithmic exponential reciprocal
box cox and neo johnson and it also
supports discretization
in intervals of equal width equal
frequency
arbitrary designed by the user
and it also supports discretization with
decision trees which was a technique
developed
in a kdd competition of 2009.
if our data has outliers and our models
are not friends of outliers we can
cup our outliers or we can actually
remove them from the data set and we can
define outliers using various techniques
for example
if it is normally distributed we can use
the mean plus minus the standard
deviation
if it's skewed we can use the
interquantal range proximity rule
we can use percentiles or we can also
copy it at the number that we think
is the one
feature engine allows us to combine
variables for example
just to see how this is useful if we're
working in finance
we can combine the total debt of a
person with the income to obtain another
variable that is called the debt to
income ratio so here we have a ratio
if a customer has debt over different
credit cards we can sum
the debt and obtain the total debt
or we can have the income minus the
expenses to obtain the disposable income
so these variables don't
come as such in the data set we need to
create them we can create them with
feature engine utilizing the
mathematical combinator
indicating which variables we want to
combine how we want to combine them and
what's the name that we want to give to
the new variable
and then with transform we perform the
transformation
in the coming months
we're going to have functionality
to work as well with daytime variables
so date and time variables cannot be
used as such
we extract a lot of information from
them like for example day
month semester year quarter hour minute
second but more importantly
we combine two time variables to
determine
time elapsed between things for example
if a customer
makes an application and i have the date
of birth i can determine the age of the
customer
some other functionality that we hope to
have soon in the package is
how to create very quick features from
text
like counting characters words unique
words lexical diversity
and how to count paragraphs and
sentences
and as lastly we
are welcoming contributors so over these
years we have had a growing number of
contributors that have come
and added new functionality to this
feature engine and
we would also love you to have you on
board so that's all
from me i'm sorry if it was a bit rushed
but i'm mindful
that we are very short of time so
if you have any questions uh
thank you very much for the talk
sergeant
i guess so if somebody from audience
wants to type a question
just type the question on the chat and i
will read it out
and in the meantime i got uh i got two
questions from myself the
first one is uh so you spoke a lot about
the
data imputation which i understand
from what i understood is to kind of
feel gaps on your data set
and if i i just got curious then to what
extent
when you when you create those
artificial values they
they risk kind of poisoning your data
set or something like that
and how do you decide between one
imputation technique or the other
yes that's actually a very good question
i think
it depends on a number of things the
first thing is
which model you want to build because if
you want to build decision trees
they are quite robust to having a number
that has nothing to do with the rest of
the distribution
so perhaps choosing the imputation
technique is not so important as when
you're building linear models because
linear models are more sensitive to the
distribution
so as general guidelines
when we're building linear models i
think we want to preserve the
distribution of the variable as much as
possible
so we want to perform we want to impute
with parameters that are intrinsic to
the variable distribution like the mean
the median or ideally
random sampling it also depends on how
much
how many missing values you have in your
variable if your variable has
few missing values then the distortion
is not going to be huge
if you have a lot of missing values then
the distortion is going to be
quite dramatic so i think you have to
play a little bit with that with with
model you're building
how many missing values you have is the
model robust to variable distortion
i don't know if that answers the
question i think yes yes sure um
then uh follow-up questions is uh
when you were talking about a feature
combination
then that from what i understood
you is creating
fields that that will be useful on your
data set that might be a combination of
an expression on the other fields
i i just got curious if you have a
massive data set
do you have any measurements on on
performance of
those functions to see that how long it
takes to
to apply on a large data set
um that's something that we still need
to do to measure
like time and performance because we're
using pandas
and numpy it shouldn't be dramatically
i mean it would be as much as those two
libraries take
um i think the more
specific question perhaps if i
understand this correctly is
when we have a large data set how do we
know
which variables to combine if we're
doing
a data science competition we probably
don't care and we just combine
everything with everything because we
just want to win but when we work within
an organization we don't do that
because we need to explain what
we produce and why we make the decisions
so the variables that we create
they have some sort of business meaning
so we create variables like for example
debt to income ratio if i have
an accident a car with an accident i can
sum
all the parts of the car that had an
accident to get a picture of the total
damage for example
but i wouldn't sum variables just
for the sake of summing variables so
there is
a bit of domain knowledge that you have
to have
to decide how you're going to combine
the variables regardless of how big the
data set is
and because of this we normally don't
work alone there is always a risk team
very familiar with the data that is an
insurance team
familiar with the data so we get a lot
of input about
what are the most meaningful variables
or the variables that the business will
need
or want answers
yes and just out of curiosity is that
something so when you have a combined
variable is that
something that physically exists or when
you ask for that field
the framework will process that and
return that value to you
when we combine variables yes and the
way
the transformer is implemented you
indicate which variables you want to
combine you indicate the operation that
you want to
perform and then you have the option to
give the new variables a name
so it will return the original data set
plus the new variables and if you gave
them a name it will
be combined under that variable name if
not it will just have
the variables something materialized
into the data set
is not a function that the x is set api
level
and process uh on the fly when you ask
them
no it's yeah no it's it's it will become
as a result so you will have
your data with the additional variables
because the whole thing is that
it needs to be able to work within the
pipeline so
that data set can be taken in by the
next transformation
or by the model so we need the results
right yeah understood so let me
check
so there is one more so since you
mentioned that you are looking for
contribute to
contributors to feature engine uh where
should people look for
developer guides on how to get started
there are a number of ways that you can
reach out to us
the first one is the github repo it has
an issues section with a number of
issues that we're working on so
if one of them is of
interesting for you you can just put
your name down to the issue start the
conversation that's one way the other
thing is that you can contact me through
linkedin or twitter um or then
if you look in the feature engine
documentation there is also guidelines
of how to contribute
it's very easy like just give me a shout
yeah so uh
yeah so i don't see any other questions
uh
so i'd like to thank you very much
for making yourself available to give us
a talk today
i would also would like to thank melissa
for taking the time and that's
basically the wrap-up for our session
today
as i mentioned we will have another
session in
about two weeks time you are all invited
and we will be releasing more
information so
soon so uh
thanks again soledad melissa and for
everybody else
see you soon thank you very much and
bye bye
you